Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Trunken von Absinnt und Opium fallen ab Diketten zerspringt die Fesselgrauen Alltags. Frei spricht nun mein Herz von der schweren Last der Tage und Träume hab ich viele warm
wird es in meiner Brust die seelisch weltunquellt vor Glück. Sei gewiss, du grüne Fee, könnte ich lieben,
Ich liebte dich.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertzehn, es grüßt euch euer führender Lyrik-Podcast. Da wo man kulturell so ausgeglichen bedient wird. Da bleibt kein Auge trocken.
Ja. Das war ein Absinngedicht aus äh anonymer Feder. Quelle Internet.
Welle Italien. Das ist ja alles total absinnt. Äh total absurd.
Ja äh besonders auch absurd ist ähm ein äh ein Link, den ich heute äh oder gestern irgendwie zugesteckt bekommen habe,
Ja, es war ganz interessant, ja äh ist ein ein Leserbrief von Allan Frances an ähm,
Die New York Times und Allen Francis ist ein emeritierter Professor der äh Psychiatrie und äh Verhaltenswissenschaften.
Ähm an der Duke University und der hat äh das einer der war einer der einer der Personen, die das DSM vier geschrieben haben.
In der vierten Auflage. Ähm.
Also so ein Handbuch für Geisteskrankheiten.
Also es gibt im Prinzip zwei offizielle,
ähm quasi Diagnose und Klassifikationswerke in der Psychologie oder in der Psychiatrie, äh das ICD zehn, das hat aber glaube ich auch andere Krankheiten drin.
Und das DSM vier und du kannst dann so jeder Krankheit oder jeder Störung oder was da alles gibt, kannst du so eine Zahl äh geben, ne?
Das DSM vier definiert äh was eine was was du haben musst,
um eine um eine oder welche Bedingung erfüllt werden müssen, damit ihr eine bestimmte äh psychische Störung oder Kondition ähm attestiert werden kann,
Das heißt natürlich definiert ähm die,
Schörungen, ne? Ne, die musst du, die musst du erfüllen, äh die müssen deren ähm Erfüllung muss quasi sichergestellt oder geprüft werden, damit du sagen kannst, die Person hat Folgendes,
Und ganz interessant ist, dass äh oder ähm spannend dabei ist, dass im der gesamte Bereich der Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Ähm wenn ich mich nicht täusche bei allen, der Fall ist, äh Persönlichkeitsstörungen sind, ähm also.
Es gibt normal, wenn ein vielleicht unter Umständen normales Verhalten,
so massiv bei dir auftritt, dass es ähm äh schweres, persönliches Leid äh hervorruft oder dich irgendwie quasi disfunktional in deinem Leben macht.
Also Depressionen zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber Depression ist keine Persönlichkeitsstörung, ne? Persönlichkeitsstörungen sind ähm also das ist hm.
Also zum Beispiel so stark wirkt, wie es auch eine Depression tut.
Genau, es gibt aber nur, es gibt relativ wenige ähm äh Persönlichkeitsstörungen. Ähm ich gucke jetzt mal gerade ganz kurz, das ist jetzt, glaube ich, etwas über zehn oder so.
Zehn verschiedene, die unterschieden werden. Hm.
Ja. Ähm ich gucke mal ganz kurz, vielleicht also das ist jetzt irgendwie Gefühl. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie viele das sind. Ähm.
Handvoll könnte man sagen.
Zwölf, ja, so äh zwölf laut Wikip nach ICD zehn, die in der WikiTedia zusammengeführt wird. Ähm in DSM fünf, das es heute gibt ähm.
Zwölf Stück, also was so Echsenmenschen an einer an zwei Händen abzählen können.
Genau, es gibt sowas wie die Paranoide Persönlichkeitsstörung, ist relativ klar, ne, das äh ähm Borderline-Persönlichkeitsstörung, das ist irgendwie bekannt. Antisoziale Persönlichkeitsstörung und natürlich auch die
nazistische Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Die wir hier angesprochen haben.
Die hier angesprochen wurde und ähm die du musst also,
um überhaupt eine Persönlichkeitsstörung zu haben, musst du ähm eben ein starkes, persönliches Leid haben, ne? Also eine signifikante Beeinträchtigung in der Funktionalität der Persönlichkeit.
Ähm.
Und äh er argumentiert und ich denke da äh hat er im Prinzip Recht leider, auch wenn ich's trotzdem anders sehe, aber er hat ein gutes Argument. Er sagt ähm,
Immer mehr Leute gehen raus und sagen ähm dass der äh Donald Trump eine narzisstische Persönlichkeitsstörung hätte,
und legen damit nah, dass er auf auf Basis psychiatrischer Gründe ähm.
Un äh äh ungeeignet ist, Präsident zu sein.
Und dann sagt er äh das ist äh falsch, denn ich habe die Kriterien für die nazistische Persönlichkeitsstörung geschrieben, aufgeschrieben
Und äh da äh und Trump äh erfüllt die nicht, denn er ist zwar ein Weltklasse-Nazist,
Aber äh das macht ihn nicht äh mental krank, weil er nicht unter Distress und Emperment leidet.
Also er leidet nicht drunter.
Er leidet nicht drunter, ja? Ähm und wenn er nicht drunter leidet, dann kann es keine Persönlichkeitsstörung sein. Das ist quasi, ja äh,
ich habe da heute äh morgen mit einem Bekannten drüber gequatscht. Ähm der dann auch sagte, wie und wenn der jetzt, sagen wir mal, wenn der jetzt abgewählt wird und sein Imperium zerbricht, dann würde er äh dann würde er ja wahrscheinlich drunter leidender seinem Narzissmus,
Und dann wäre das auf einmal Diagnosefähig und im Zweifelsfall lautet die Antwort ja. Und das ist der äh Individuumszentrierten Perspektive der äh der Psychologie äh geschuldet. Die natürlich hier sagt,
Wenn du das nicht machen würdest, dann könnten ja die ganzen, könnte, könnten ja alle möglichen Verhaltensweisen,
Ähm die du äußerst ähm.
Quasi wie nennt man das pathologisiert werden, ne? Dann könnten ja alle daher kommen und sagen, du hast folgendes.
Zu Krankheiten erklärt werden.
Genau, du bist krank, du bist krank, du bist krank. Und das geht aber nur, ne? Also deswegen sagen sie auch, äh stehen sie hier da äh äh,
erzwingen sie hier, das geht nur, wenn du selber auch darunter leidest, hier kann nicht jemand, wenn du nicht leidest, eine Krankheit diagnostizieren. Kam die interessante Gegenfrage so sinngemäß. Na ja, aber was ist denn irgendwie ein, ne, ein ein Serienmörder und ähm,
und sonstiger, ne? Der äh total ausgeglichen ist und nicht leidet, ne? Und äh die Antwort lautet, naja, ähm volle Schuldfähigkeit, ne?
Also das ist halt, den brauchst du ja nicht zu diagnostizieren, den der kommt halt in den Knast, ne? Also äh dem wenn der halt nicht diagnostizierbar ist, dann hat er sicherlich auch keine,
mildernden Umstände und dann kriegst du halt die volle Strafe. Ähm insofern wird der sich da schon was anderes überlegen. Aber grundsätzlich, ne? Äh
ist dieser Punkt hier denke ich ein Valida, trotzdem würde ich sagen, dass Trump gestört ist und Sumi. Äh.
Ähm aber er sagt äh und das ist der der wichtige Punkt. Das ist auch nicht nur ein äh technisches äh wissenschaftliches Statement, was er hier macht, sondern auch ein politischer, er sagt, Mister Trump Corses, Cevir des Trest,
denn Experience singet. Also er macht den Leuten ähm,
ungemach und Angst äh außer, dass äh im Gegensatz dazu, dass er selber merkt. Und äh er wurde,
Reich entlohnt und belohnt dafür äh und nicht äh nicht bestraft. Ähm.
Und dann sagt er jetzt, ist stigmatisierend die mental Kranken, das ist jetzt sein Begriff hier ähm zu stigmatisieren.
Indem man sie mit Donald Trump vergleicht, ne? Das ist immer, das finde ich immer geil. Finde ich sehr schön. Also sie sagte, es ist stigmatisierend für für mental Erkrankte, äh dass man sie auf ein Niveau mit Donald Trump stellt,
der nämlich nicht mental krank ist und dann sagt er schlechtes Verhalten ist selten ein Zeichen mentaler Krankheit,
Weil die mental Kranken sich nur selten schlecht verhalten. Ähm Donald Trump,
Impacty and Persod of dictutorial Powers.
Also er spricht ihm im Prinzip auch äh jegliche Schuldminderung ab, ne. Das muss man hier äh äh er spricht ihm jegliche äh schuldmildernde Umstände ab und sagt er ist vollständig.
Schuldfähig und äh das das Gegengift äh der der Trump Dystopie ist ein politisches und nicht ein äh psychologisches.
So äh der emeritierte Professor Ellen Frances.
Zur Frage der Persönlichkeitsstörung. Wie gesagt, ich würde
ich widersetze mich dem bereitwillig und sage der Trieb ist gestört. Vielleicht ist es keine Persönlichkeitsstörung, aber da müssen wir halt an den werden wir's halt irgendwie müssen wir's halt Trumpismus nennen oder sowas, wo woran der junge der der arme Mann leidet.
Ne, aber genau dieses er leidet ja nicht.
Ja, na ja, vielleicht gibt's ja in dem nächsten noch einen neuen Eintrag in DSM vier.
Es gibt äh ein DSM fünf inzwischen.
Ach so, das ist auch noch eine Seriennummer, ja. Okay.
Dann in ähm in aller Munde nach der letzten Sendung war äh ob ob denn äh ich glaube es war es richtet sich hauptsächlich gegen dich, ob du jetzt Netzsperrer gefordert hättest.
Netzwerken gefordert.
Ja, nee, Quatsch.
Was möchtest du zu deiner welche Persönlichkeitsstörung möchtest du zu deiner Verteidigung anführen.
Nee, nee, das ist keine Persönlichkeitsstörung, weil ich erzeuge ja Stress bei den anderen. Mir geht's ja super,
Ja, also äh das Ganze ist so ein bisschen aus dem Kontext herausgegriffen worden, wo wir darüber gesprochen haben, was denn Face
so tun könnte gegen die Verbreitung von äh Fake News. Da hatten wir ja das äh ein oder andere äh debattiert, unter anderem eben auch so diese Frage
wie wie erkennt man denn sozusagen aktiv arbeitende Gruppen die ja.
Bewusst oder unbewusst ähm in auffälligen Mengen Falschmeldungen produzieren und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ähm,
war das quasi mein Aufhänger, dass ich gesagt habe, ja an der Stelle gäbe es ja dann durchaus auch die Möglichkeit, so einen so einen Penalty einzuführen für Facebook, ne. Ähm das war natürlich jetzt kein, kein, kein Vorschlag zu einer,
Etablierung eines Sperrsystems auf Netzebene. Hier geht's ja sozusagen nur dadrum, wie operiert
Facebook selber, da Facebook ja selber ein ein großer Haufen von Algorithmen und Priorisierung ist und seine
Jedermanns Timeline halt nach äh eigenem Gutdünken und nach eigenen Algorithmen zusammenbaut und Dinge eben auch bewusst weglässt und dir den Rest, den du vielleicht noch erreichen möchtest, dann auch gerne noch zusätzlich verkauft,
trotzdem aber eben mit diesem Problem konfrontiert ist,
Maßnahmen ergreifen zu müssen oder vielleicht sehen sie es noch nicht, dass sie es müssen, aber zumindest verdienen das ja nahegelegt, dass sie, dass sie welche ergreifen, dass man eben.
Solche Organisationen unter Umständen eben auch mit einem Malos äh versorgen kann, sprich man verliert halt innerhalb von Facebook seinen äh Posting-Fähigkeiten, wenn man eben nachweislich,
viel Scheiße da rein produziert die halt nachweislich einfach nicht stimmt.
Tust du äh an anderen Stellen ja zum Beispiel auch, ne? Wir äh also erstens muss man ja zu der einen Teil, den wir bewusst ein bisschen ausgeblendet haben, ist.
Das ist ja ein Problem.
Oder zumindest den Umstand gibt, dass äh Facebook in Deutschland äh jetzt nicht irgendwie sich nennenswert rechtlich gebunden fühlt
Ähm Ulf Burmeier hatte das ja auch als er zuletzt bei uns zu Gast war, nochmal ähm ausgeführt äh dass Facebook im Prinzip sagt äh deutsche Gesetze das
diese gesamte, diese Gesamtvarianz in Gesetz und so, das können wir uns eigentlich nicht leisten. Da haben wir keinen Bock drauf. Wir machen hier US US-Loor und fertig.
Und das wird ja ähm bemängelt. Und.
Um der äh hier unser äh AD hat dann auch ähm ich meine, da gibt's eigentlich wenig hinzuzufügen zu dem, was er dazu zu dem Thema,
kommentiert hat, nämlich Moment also zu der Frage.
Ist das Entfernen von irgendwas auf Facebook eine Netzsperre, sagt er. In der Netzsperrendebatte ging,
um die Internetprovider und letztlich einen Aspekt von Netzneutralität. Nämlich ob
Inhalte ohne Kontrolle durchgeleitet werden, ne? Also da ging's ja darum, dass man komplette IP-Adresse, einen kompletten äh DNS-Eintrag sperrt, ne? Also Facebook sperrt oder so, ne? Während es aber weiterhin existiert,
Facebook ist aber äh kein reiner Hoster, der nur den Zugriff auf bestimmte Informationen ermöglicht, sondern hat Mechanismen der Verbreitung. Dazu kommt der Dienst verfügt bereits über eine Infrastruktur zur Inhaltskontrolle.
Weiter sagt er, aber vor allem, wie du sagst, der Slogan war nicht stehenlassen statt sperren,
Äh also er bezieht sich auf die äh Stoppshirt-Debatte, die wir in Deutschland hatten. Da war nämlich der Slogan löschen statt sperren. Also auch da hat die äh äh Netzgemeinde ähm,
für für das Löschen von illegalen Inhalten plädiert, ne? Ganz im Gegensatz zu dem,
bären, welches ja nur ein ein Verstecken von illegalen Inhalten wäre ohne weitere Strafverfolgung. AD schreibt also weiter, wenn man also weiß, dass es sich um etwas Illegales, Galles handelt, soll es entfernt werden. In diesem Fall,
anerkannt verleumderische Falschinformation über eine Person.
Das Ziel ist ja, dass die Information gar nicht auftaucht und nicht, dass die Zugänglichkeit eingeschränkt wird. Selbst wenn man Facebook nur als Hoster verstehen würde
könnte ihn von der Rechtsdurchsetzung mal abgesehen, also hier bezieht er sich auf das äh Problem, was Ulf angesprochen hatte. Gerichtig auferlegt werden, einen bestimmten,
illegalen Inhalt zu löschen und anschließend zu verhindern, dass er nochmal eingestellt wird. Also die Unterlassung passiert jeden Tag, ne,
mit allen möglichen Kram, insbesondere im Bereich des Urheberrechts interessanterweise, genau das ist ja hier in einem sehr hinkenden Vergleich, auch unserem Tobi,
passiert, ne? Der, der Tobistricks, Tobi, dem wurde ja auch gesagt, das darfst du jetzt einfach nicht mehr verbreiten, fertig. Thema erledigt, so, ne?
Ja, also ist keine äh natürlich keine einfache Debatte, das hat sich ja in den letzten Wochen und Monaten schon auch äh gezeigt und auch wir suchen nur nach Antworten.
Ich fand nochmal wichtig, wir haben letzte Woche gar nicht so herausgestellt, dass was der äh Markus Reuter auf Netzpolitik Octa auch nochmal zugeschrieben hat, hat gesagt, Schuld, dass wir diese Scheißdebatte haben müssen, sind irgendwelche dämlichen, rechten Hetzer, die nicht mit dem Internet umgehen können,
Die treten uns jetzt diesen Mist ein, ja? Ähm da hat er einen Punkt. So, NS Aua.
Du warst da.
Ich war jetzt zweimal im NSA.
Insgesamt. Insgesamt. Nicht zweimal hintereinander oder doch.
Und hintereinander beides. Das ist ja nicht exklusiv, das.
Ach so. Das ist ja nicht exklusiv. Doch heute auch nochmal.
Nein, ich war ähm am dreizehnten da und bei der Sitzung davor. Ich weiß aber nicht genau, wann die war. Heute konnte ich nicht, musste ich Podcasten. Nein, ich musste ich muss, hätte eigentlich arbeiten müssen. Und ähm heute war auch schwierig äh Tickets zu kriegen.
Weil heute war ja Merkel Stargast da.
Also die die äh die Südkurve.
Dicht gefüllt.
Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich, das müsste die Südkurve sein, wo ähm.
Wo so technische Aufklärung, Andre Meister und so alle immer sitzen.
Die Südkurve, die Netzpolitische Südkurv.
Auer Ultras, ja. Ähm also ich habe da den Profaler mir angeguckt, das kann man sich kaum angucken. Also das war wirklich schwierig.
Und ähm deswegen gebe ich mal hier auf die Sitzung vom dreizehnten ein, weil die beim in meinen Gedanken noch ein bisschen frischer ist. Ähm da bin ich ein bisschen später auch gekommen.
Habe den ersten Zeugen Herrn Fritsche nicht mitbekommen oder nur das Ende mitbekommen. Dann habe ich mir den Altmaier angeguckt.
Der Chef BK Altmaier, kennst du, ne? Ein äh begabter Politiker, unglaublich, der ähm also das war eine auf zwei Ebenen.
Eine also sehr interessant ihm zuzuhören.
Erstens natürlich auf der auf der inhaltlichen Ebene, wie er sich also gegen verschiedene Verdächtigungen und Vorwürfe da ähm elegant,
zur Wehr gesetzt hat, ne? Und immer wieder so,
Also die der gesamte NS-Auer ist eigentlich nur so ein Hütchenspiel, ne? Er ist immer so, wo ist er denn? Nee, hier sie nicht, ne? Waren die anderen?
Dann kommen die anderen rein und sagen, hier ist er auch nicht. Oh, jetzt ist hier die Matte sogar schon umgekipp,
keine Ahnung. Und du zahlst immer rein, ne? Du musst immer Ressourcen reinbuttern und dann denkst du irgendwie, du kriegst dein Geld zurück und dann meinst du, hast, du hast das kleine Küken gesehen, aber äh ne, die sind halt besser als du
Und das kannst du dir im im NS Auer äh konntest du das jetzt über hundert Sitzungen anschauen.
Ähm das war äh der andere interessante äh Aspekt. Altmaier kommt also da so rein und der äh geht dann erstmal und begrüßt wirklich jeden einzelnen.
Somit äh mit mit Hand geben. Ne? Wir kennen uns hallo. Ja, Mensch, ey, sup.
Haben uns schon oft getroffen und wir werden uns auch wieder treffen.
So mal, dass du hier bist und so, ne? Auch so mit so ähm die haben sich jetzt auch gerade,
Jetzt schweife ich ein bisschen ab, aber so wie wie Donald Trump Hände gibt, ne? Das ist ja auch nochmal so ein ganz anderes Thema, aber wir woll.
Hältst du so ganz lange fest und gibst nicht wieder h.
Ja, aber also okay, diese Trump-Sache ist eh nochmal total witzig, weil der äh in einem Buch neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig schon gesagt hat, dass er ein äh German Fobe ist. Also jemand.
Eigentlich große äh große Abneigung gespürt, wenn er fremden Leuten die Hand geben muss, weil er nicht weiß, wo die war und dann sich sehr gerne schnell die Hand äh waschen möchte. Ähm das hat er offenbar, das überspielt er sehr gut, wie er jetzt ähm.
Er hat ja auch in einem Buch geschrieben, dass er sich auch gerne selber mal vorher noch in den Hintern fasst und dann äh den anderen sozusagen die Germans weiterreicht, aber jetzt kommen wir zu sehr in die Details. Bleiben wir bei ähm Peter Altmaier.
Bleiben wir bei Alpeter Altmaier, Peter Altmaier, muss man einfach sagen, der Mann,
hat Stil. So, der hat das sehr sehr gut gemacht. Das war äh auf auf dieser Ebene eben eine Wonne ihm zuzuschauen, wie der das schafft,
sich die da alle so zu zähmen
ne? Also so, ne, erstmal allen schön die Hand geben, noch ein nettes Wörtchen, ne? Und dann ich meine, du bist fucking äh Zeuge in einem äh parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss, wo du eigentlich einer der Hauptbeschuldigten bist
Du bist der Chef des Bundeskanzleramtes so. Alle wissen, du hast Scheiße gebaut,
Der geht erstmal so hin, der muss immer so so, muss ja so so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so einen Beschuldigten vor Gericht vorstellen, die erstmal so zu allen geht, ne und den Zeugen so die Hand gibt, ne? Noch ein nettes Wort wechselt. Ähm
Und dann erstmal so anfängt in seinem Eingangsstatement, erstmal so sagt sie, ja. Also erstmal so.
Tolle Arbeit, die sie hier alle geleistet haben. Ich habe das Gebant verfolgt, ich habe das auch auf der Webseite Netzpolitik dot org immer gelesen, was sie hier machen und wie sie ja alle wissen.
Habe ich ähm äh ja immer auch.
Stark mich dafür gemacht dafür zu sorgen, dass der parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschuss,
alles alle Kraft hat äh untersuchen kann, dass das Mandat entsprechend ausgeweitet wird und habe sie immer unterstützt,
Das sagt der Typ, der äh zum Beispiel diese diese Graulichkapriolen da geschlagen hat, ne,
ich mein die Bundesregierung hat ja bei jeder Gelegenheit gegen den NSA gekämpft, ne und hat den versucht irgendwie
den Untersuchungsgegenstand nicht zu zugestehen, hatte versucht den Snowden Ladung nicht zu zulassen und so. Im Einfluss genommen noch und Nöcher und haben das Ding an einer kurzen Leine gehalten. Aber der Altmaier ist so einer, der setzt sich da rein, der schafft, dass sowas zu sagen,
Und dann sitzen da so sage ich mal weniger erfahrene Kandidaten und die dann da so sitzen so,
Das ist das richtige, du wählen so mit einem Schwanz und warten, dass Altmaier noch ein Leckerli wirft, ne.
Jetzt noch ein Witz.
Der hat mich gelobt, ne? Der, der kommt dann so, kommt dann hier,
abends nach Hause und sagt dann, heute hat der der Peter Altmaier, hat gesagt, das haben wir gut gemacht im im Pur, ne. Einer, der da wirklich sehr von äh angetan war, war äh Marian Wendt, also dem zuzuschauen, war wiederum eine Qual
Also das ist wirklich das äh CDU äh Vertreter, der ist so ähm Anfang dreißig ähm und ähm ich also.
Untersuchungsausschuss.
Ja, also der ähm ich sage mal, also.
Peter, was soll ich dazu jetzt sagen, ne? Also in Diplomverwaltungswirt und Master of Law.
Nur Fakten, keinen, kein Unterstell.
Da wo ich herkomme, gibt es keine äh freundlichen Worte für für das was er da getan hat. Deswegen kann ich das jetzt nur ähm inhaltlich beschreiben, was er getan hat. Also.
Marian Wende ist dann so so sehr der verteidigt dann sogar noch so quasi wenn dann so die Opposition dran ist, ne? Und dann sagen wir irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, jetzt irgendwie Andre Hahn von der Linken oder äh oder Konstantin von Notz, von der Grünen stellen dann mal so eine,
Frage und dann dann hast du so einen Marian, wenn der sich dann empört,
So, das ist nicht untersuchungsgegenständig oder oder so, das das hat er schon gesagt oder dass es darum geht's hier überhaupt nicht und in so einem Versuch, denn der nimmt dann noch so den Zeugen in Schutz, ne? Also es ist absurd.
Sowie Breitbart News auf den Trump äh Pressekonferenzen.
Der ist es absurd, ja? Also wenn er dann, wenn er dann auch mal fragen darf, dann stellt er und jetzt muss ich tatsächlich sagen, dass ich mich nicht mehr genau ich mich jetzt persönlich gerade nicht erinnere. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass er diese Frage Altmaier äh,
gestellt hat, ne? Und das geht ja dann auch immer rundum mit den Fragen, dann kommen diese Fragerunden und jeder, dann haben die ja unterschiedlich viel Zeit für ihre Fragen, ne? Also die,
Opposition, äh, die, die, äh, die haben dann immer 'ne quasi 'ne Zeit läuft ab.
Mhm.
Und als dann Marian Wendt dran war mit Fragen, dann stellt er sowas wie ähm tun wir bereits alles,
Um Bürger, Unternehmen und Verwaltung vor Angriffen von außen zu Schutz zu schützen. Was muss politisch finanziell und aus anderen Gründen noch getan werden?
So, wo man dann eigentlich mal sagen müsste, Kollege, das ist nun wirklich nicht Untersuchungsgegenständlich,
dass du die die Fragezeit im im parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss, ja? Dein Parteikollegen
in den Arsch steckst mit Zucker obendrauf, damit der noch ein bisschen Werbung machen kann, ne? Also das ist ähm wie gesagt, Marian Wendt, das ist echt eine, das muss man auch mal gesehen haben. Das muss man gesehen haben. Ähm.
Also über eine völlig andere Person äh wurde mal gesagt, das ist so ein Arschkriecher, der wird es nochmal weit bringen.
War aber über jemand anders.
Demnächst im Iran Kin.
So, dann ähm,
Thema, also genau, Altmaier. Thema, dann waren Nose bei Abkommen, ne? Also das Noseby-Abkommen ist deshalb im im NS-Aua das große Thema, mit dem dann die Leute vom äh Bundeskanzleramt ähm beschäftigt werden.
Ähm weil das ja halt eines dieser Wahlkampfversprechen war,
zweitausenddreizehn war Bundestagswahl und wir hatten da da musste Merkel neu gewählt werden und entsprechend hatten wir da solche Profalas-Rom-Rennen, die die Affäre für beendet erklärt haben,
uns wurde ein No-Spy-Abkommen in Aussicht gestellt und der eine der Fragen, eine der zentralen Fragen, die dieser parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschuss natürlich auch untersucht ist, war dieses Nord bei Abkommen,
jemals in greifbarer Nähe oder handelt es sich um ein falsches Wahlkampfversprechen, das sie selber nicht mehr hätten machen können zu diesem Zeitpunkt, weil klar war, dass es das niemals geben würde,
Und da sagt natürlich Altmaiern wir in Deutschland hatten allen Anlass zu der Annahme, dass die USA ernsthaft
Interesse an Verhandlungen hätten, die haben auch stattgefunden und dann gab es unterschiedliche Texte äh für ein derartiges Nosfallabkommen. In einigen Punkten war man sich einig in anderen nicht. Und die zentrale Uneinigkeit war.
Dass die USA sich nicht verpflichten wollten, geltendes Recht eines anderes Land eines anderen Landes einzuhalten
Das ist aber auch normal als Auslandsgeheimdienst hältst du dich nicht an geltendes Recht eines anderen Landes, ne? Also ich meine, du bist ja ausgeheimdienst. Du bist dafür da, äh das Gericht anderer Länder. Kannst ja nicht sagen, ach scheiße.
Wir können in in äh in in Deutschland können wir nicht spionieren, das ist da verboten.
Alle wieder abreißen.
Das geht halt, ne?
Thema Ramstein, Ramstein ist natürlich Thema, weil äh weil es ja die haben ja eine Sendung mit Konstanz auch nochmal ausführlich besprochen, weil es eine Release-Station für diese Drohnen
Angriffe in in anderen Ländern ist und damit eben an Völkerrechtswidrigen Tätigkeiten eine entscheidende Rolle spielt. Na, sagt er dann natürlich, also ich kann nicht erkennen, dass in Ramstein Dinge geschehen, die mit den vertraglichen Bedingungen nicht vereinbar sind,
Ich kann nicht entscheiden, wie es technisch,
von funktioniert, weil ich habe mich nie, weil ich habe mir das nicht angeschaut, aber ich bin fest überzeugt, äh dass die Ministerien das ordentlich prüfen,
und sich gemeldet hätten, wenn das was wenn da was Völkerrechtliches stattfinden würde. Er ist ja jetzt zum Beispiel wieder so schön, ne? Sind sagt er, ich bin der spielt er den Ball so an die Ministerien, ne.
In der nächsten Sitzung wird der dann wieder zurückgespielt, ne? Und dann das ist so dieses Hütchen.
Da ja als Ministerium nichts machen, weil das Bundeskanzleramt und ja, ja.
Also keiner war am Ende schuld, ne? Ähm.
Ist auch eigentlich nichts passiert.
Dann hat er, dann hat er nochmal gesagt, dann hat er äh nochmal den den Pur, die Leviten gelesen und hat gesagt, also es ist
Es ist sehr wichtig für uns, dass wir äh nicht das Image bekommen, dass Informationen, die äh an Deutschland weitergegeben, dort nicht sicher sind, ne? Das würde die drastisch die Zusammenarbeit mit unseren Geheimdiensten einschränken,
und hat dann mehrmals gesagt, also er würde jetzt hier niemanden, er würde jetzt hier niemanden scharf angucken oder beschuldigen wollen, aber es wäre ja schon eine ganze Menge aus der Geheimdienstkontrolle auch gelegt äh und aber er würde jetzt auch hier nicht den Ströbele äh schaffen.
Schön finde ich auch, dass er, dass er, dass er nicht meint, dass dass die äh Dateien nicht sicher sind, sondern nur, dass es wichtig ist, dass man nicht das Image bekommt, dass es so sei, ja.
Ja, ja. Ähm dann sagt der immer bei.
Also wir wir können auch zum Beispiel über Loch Bodennetzpolitik weiter eine Menge Scheiße erzählen. Hauptsache wir kriegen nicht das Image, dass wir eine Menge Scheiße erzählen. Solange die Leute nur davon reden, wie geil das alles ist, passt es schon.
Ähm,
Er sagt dann so als Fazit zu diesem NSA, sagt er dann auch an der äh wie gesagt, er ist die ganze Zeit sehr jung und sagt dann, also wenn auch nicht immer hier die Sensationen rausgekommen sind, die Herr Hahn und Notz, sich vielleicht erhofft haben, ähm
wollte er sich jetzt trotzdem nur mal für die hervorragende Arbeit äh des pur danken und äh viele Punkte entdeckt, wo Änderungen vorgenommen wurden.
Also parlamentarischer Untersuchungsausschuss.
Aber er hätte, ne, weil er das ja verfolgt hat, auch dann auch auf Netzpolitik dort, oh, konnte er das ja verfolgen, dann haben sie viele Änderungen vorgenommen und dann denkst du dir, du sitzt da und denkst dir so.
Welche denn? Du hattest doch jetzt gerade mehrere Stunden Aussagezeit, um zu erklären, welche, ne? Und da ist er natürlich dat er natürlich nicht nennenswert was zu gesagt, ne? Insbesondere ähm,
Ist ja das Fazit dieses NS Auer, dass man da irgendwie den Schindler rausgeworfen hat? Mehr ist da nicht passiert, ne? Es gibt mehr Konsequenzen gibt's in Deutschland.
Doch, es gibt ein neues Pipa, äh neues Gesetz für BKA und äh der Etat ist aufgestockt worden für den Verfassungsschutz, also.
Danke, wir haben viel entdeckt, wo wir nachbessern, was das meinte, der Entschuldigung, natürlich, ja.
Dich.
Das meinte er. Wenn äh zu dieser Merkel-Handy-Sache mal zweifelte er das dann auch noch an. Ja, sagt also, Merkels Telefonnummer bekommt man überall her und alles, was es da gab, war irgendwie ein Blattpapier, wo die draufstand als Spionageziel. Das heißt auch lange nicht, das.
Aber der, der kriegt das halt auch hin, dass da Leute sitzen und es äh das abnicken, ne? Also so ein, so ein hier mein, also Marian Fendt, ich sehe es so geil. Der, wie gesagt, der, der wird nochmal, der wird nochmal weit kommen.
Der twitterte ja dann auf irgendwie ausführlich, ne? Sowas wie vor der Sitzung, ne? Twittert der dann nochmal.
Ist auch so ein Twitterer, ne?
Na ja, der hat irgendwie achthundert Follower oder so, ne, aber also er ist ein Twitterer, ja, der ist echt ein Twitterer. Also, Marian Wendt ähm.
Also Mare, ich ich möchte über Marian Wendt mal.
Wer hat achthundert, wer hat achthundert Follower? Marian Wett hat achthunder.
Achthundertundneun Follower,
Aber ne? Also wer der hat auf jeden Fall die Nortifications an auf seinem Handy, wenn er bei Twitter erwähnt wird.
Ausprobiert.
Mir ist das nur aufgefallen, ich habe, ich kann ja Twitter lesen, ich bin ja kein ähm Mitglied des äh
ersten parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss und da äh stünde da in der Pflicht mit Aufmerksamkeit dieser Sache zu folgen, äh gemäß des Mandats, äh was mir da erteilt wurde, aber der Marian Wendt
macht das auch, denn Steffen Zeibert erwähnt Marian Wind.
Ähm Steffen Zeibert war äh nachher noch Zeuge, also zwei äh nach Altmaier und ähm,
Steffen Zeibert twitterte, ich muss ich mal ganz kurz raussuchen.
Steffen Zeibert äh twitterte, ich muss zugeben, dass ich vor der Anhörung im NSA Bammel hatte, aber mit Fendo, Fanboys wie Marian Wendt hat man nichts zu befürchten,
guter Mann. Und äh ich sage mal, das Gesicht von Marian Wendt, als er dann in der Sekunde zum Handy griff und irgendwie da drauf guckte,
Das war schon Gold wert.
Und äh so eine äh äh
er verdautet also irgendwie ein paar Minuten paar Sekunden drauf rum und dann reichte er, dass er in seinen Sitznachbar und innerhalb kürzester Zeit war dann die gesamte äh CDU äh Vertreter im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss äh eher mit Twitter beschäftigt als äh Steffen Seibert äh zuzuhören, der da gerade aussagte und eh nur von der Opposition geärgert wurde
ne? Da guckt man lieber mal Twitter,
Was ich übrigens unmöglich finde, ne? Also muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also.
Ähm diese, also man könnte so ein Untersuchungsausschuss mal ernst nehmen durchaus, ne? Und.
Ach so, jetzt sind da nur noch drei Sitzungen. Es war.
Nee, ist vorbei, es ist heute ist die letzte.
Ja, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war es ja nur noch die drittstä.
War's nur noch eine? Ja, aber egal. Ähm also finde ich ähm,
Wie gesagt, der werdet noch weit bringen. Ähm bei Steffen Seibert, der dann abends noch ähm als Zeuge da geladen war, war dann äh die äh das die Aussage ausspähen unter Freunden
Das geht gar nicht, weil da äh Gegenstand der Befragung hm und da geht's natürlich um die Frage zu welchem Zeitpunkt wussten die eigentlich,
Was beim BND so abgeht? Äh und äh wie können dann solche Aussagen getätigt werden? Äh und äh es war ganz interessant, weil dann ähm,
Konstantin von Notz ihn so ungefähr sinngemäß fragte so, ja äh sagen sie mal, sie sind ja so der der Regierungssprecher und so, na, wie kommt das denn eigentlich mit diesem Ausspähen unter Freunden? Das geht gar nicht. Wo kommt das denn her? Und dann sagte Seiber, jetzt irgendwie so, ja, das war aber eine.
Emotionale Reaktion von Angela Merkel oder so, ne? Und Konstantin von Notz sagte, nee, das haben sie vorher dreimal gesagt, Herr Seibert, so an verschiedenen, also irgendwie in in Bundespressekonferenzen hatte er das nämlich schon
äh gesagt, das war also quasi etwas, was äh also in in Abwandlung hatte er diese Formulierung eh schon gesagt. Und äh Konstantin Vonotz sagte dann irgendwie so, dass er ihn
verdächtigt der Urheber äh dieses Satzes und dieser Strategie zu sein, ne? Ähm ähm,
aber auch da kommen also ich mein Seibert ist halt ein Profi, ne? Also in in einem in einem Untersuchungsausschuss, der letztendlich wie eine verlängerte Pressekonferenz abläuft
wo die Leute irgendwie so antworten müssen jedes Mal, wenn's brenzlig ist, hat sie ja diesen Vertreter der Bundesregierung, den Herrn Wolf da, der dann sagt, das ist aber nicht untersuchungsgegenständig, oder? Das können wir nur in geheimer Sitzung machen oder so.
Ähm da kann denen nichts passieren und das sitzt auch so ein Steffen Seibert äh auf einer Backe ab, genauso wie der ähm.
Wie der Peter Altmaier. Jetzt haben wir äh relativ ja wir haben kurz versucht ein bisschen Überblick über die Inhalte zu geben. Mehr dazu gibt's natürlich immer bei Netzpolitik Org,
ähm in dem in den Vollprotokollen, die Andre Meister äh dort äh angefertigt hat in in diesen beiden Sitzungen, wo ich war. Ähm und auch im Podcast technische Aufklärung, wo diese Dinge nochmal in
in größeren Zusammenhang gesetzt, wenn ich wollte jetzt gezielt so ein bisschen mal die Themen und aber auch so ein bisschen von der.
Vollklore, da äh wiedergeben.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass wir dann etwas weiter ins Jahr gedacht ähm dem ganzen Epos auch nochmal eine Sonderausgabe widmen werden.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich ich habe auch, also ich bin mal gespannt, wie technische Aufklärung jetzt weitermacht, ne? Die also das.
Arbeitslos.
Ja, ich meine, die haben ja verschiedene Optionen, das Projekt weiterzu.
Ja, wollen wir hoffen, dass die Korruption dann die Missachtung internationaler Gesetzgebung auch weiterhin fortgesetzt wird, denn ergibt sich vielleicht eine neue Gelegenheit. Ein Untersuchungsausschuss zu begleiten.
Äh und heute ne, wie gesagt, äh ist Angela Merkel dort und Marian, wenn freute sich auch heute schon, ganz früh morgen,
Letzte Sitzung des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses. Heute mit einer besonderen Zeugin.
Aber äh am dreizehnten Februar vor dem äh vor dem äh vor dieser Sitzung twitterte er. Die letzte Woche im NS-Aua hat begonnen, massenhaften, unkontrollierten und illegalen Datenabriff,
wir auch bisher nicht feststellen. Also der Typ ist äh eine Studie wert.
Die NSA-Sache ist damit jetzt erledigt. Also heute ist die letzte Anhörung, ne,
Die werden während wir sprechen, spricht Angela Merkel dort ähm zu den Themen Ausspähen unter Freunden geht gar nicht. Ähm und solchen Dingen.
Das heißt eigentlich auch, dass dieser, dass diese Affäre dann jetzt auch mehr oder weniger ihr Ende findet. Ähm
Es wird von Angela Merkel da jetzt nichts Großartiges mehr zu erwarten sein, also es wäre jetzt wirklich
sehr überraschend, wenn eine professionelle Politikerin wie Angela Merkel sich auskennt in der letzten Sitzung des NSA vollständig in die Nässe entsetzt und wir morgen einen neuen Kanzler haben oder eine neue Kanzlerin haben,
ist unwahrscheinlich. Ähm insofern kann man das Fazit ziehen. Schindler ähm musste gehen. Ähm den,
Konnte man auch, war wohl der, den man am besten ähm ähm abschießen.
Philipp Wolf, der Vertreter der Bundesregierung
sagte dazu die die Umstände der Entlassung eines politischen Beamten unterliegen, der Option keinen Grund zu nennen
Also das war auch immer wieder Thema, das wurden dann Profal äh wurde äh Altmaier gefragt, ne, warum habt ihr denn den Schindler entlassen und dann sagten sie, ja nein, das darf zu müssen wir nichts sagen. Das dazu müssen wir keine Aussage treffen.
Und ähm im Zweifelsfall ist es einfach, äh man hat ihn halt äh,
ähm gefeuert, musste dann nicht mehr äh klären, woran er wirklich Schuld war und woran nicht. Notfalls kann man ihm äh.
Kann man ihm die Schuld geben. Abgesehen davon war er eigentlich erst seit zwanzig zwölf BND Präsident. Das heißt, er war für den ganzen Mist sicherlich nicht verantwortlich, aber er war,
billiges Opfer und damit scheint diese Affäre. Jetzt beendet zu sein langsam und das ist natürlich dann schon auch,
etwas ernüchternd, als Ergebnis und Konsequenz während die ähm,
Die wie wir gerade schon herausgearbeitet haben, die Punkte auf die äh Altmaier aufmerksam geworden ist, die sich ändern müssen mit dem neuen BND-Gesetz jetzt auch geändert werden. Äh dann sind also die Defizite jetzt langsam.
Geklärt.
Tja, dabei ist nichts so, dass wir jetzt nichts äh gelernt hätten, wenn wir mal in so einer großen Krise sind, da wissen wir auch schon, wie wir die Hände zu schütteln äh haben und die Leute schülen, schön mit dem warmen Nutella-Pinsel da durch die Reihen durchgehen und immer ordentlich ums Maul.
Er ist da sehr begnadet. Hatte, also er hat auch er hat auch nein, der hat muss ich wirklich sagen, der hat das drauf und er sagt dann auch irgendwie so, dann sagt er, also wirklich schön, sagt er,
Sie müssen sich die Arbeit im Bundeskanzleramt so vorstellen, dass immer genügend davon vorhanden ist. Finde ich sehr witzig.
Das wovon genügend vorhanden ist? Wäre es noch schöner.
Von der Arbeit. Sie müsste sich jetzt habe ich dir einen Witz erklärt, das schneiden wir nachher äh schneiden wir nachher nochmal schön. Sitze erklären wir nicht, da lachen wir gemeinsam. Ähm.
Der BND währenddessen hat natürlich auch nicht geschlafen und hat sich äh überlegt, was machen wir als nächstes Freunde? Absinn.
Sind das himmlische Kind.
Und zwar stellt sich raus, dass das äh dass äh die Satellitentelefonüberwachung ähm vor einer Herausforderung steht, denn es gibt ähm.
Neue Inmasat-Dienste. In Masad ist ein Satellitentelefonienetz
da kommen jetzt die äh Satelliten der dritten Generation werden im nächsten Jahr abgeschaltet und kommen neue äh Dienste der der vierten und fünften Generation äh in den Umlauf und das heißt da muss man sich ähm,
Nachrichtendienstlich natürlich dann auch nachrüsten. Ja, das heißt äh ne, es gibt eine neue äh Satellitenkommunikationstechnologie, es gibt ein Upgrade, also brauchen wir.
Auch ein Upgrade. Das kann ja nicht sein, dass da was rumfliegt, was man nicht abhören kann.
Und dann sagen sie und das Schöne ist, dass diese neueren Satellitentelefoniegenerationen
nicht mehr irgendwelche Reigenstandards haben, sondern zu zunehmend auf Voiceover IP und E-Mailartige Systeme äh äh setzen, das heißt, es ist eine Synergie mit der Interneterfassung zu erwarten
da Entwicklungsleistung als Satelliten und Kabelansätzen beidseitig verwendet werden können. So ist also die Nachrichtendienstliche Sicht auf ähm alles IP,
das heißt natürlich auch für die Nachrichtendienste, geil, okay, wird billiger, ne? Das heißt, die wir müssen nicht mehr, haben nicht mehr so viele verschiedene spezifische Techniken und können viel auf auf gleiche Infrastruktur am Ende werfen. Dem ent äh dem zugehörig ist das Projekt
Serverus. Ach so, ab Sinn steht für Ausbau bestehender Systeme in Massad an neue technische Herausforderungen.
Ab sind. Viel Spaß beim nächsten Absinntrausch.
Ausbau bestehender Systeme.
In Massad an, neue technische Herausforderungen.
Also die brauchen auch jetzt nicht in Massad aus.
Naja, die nennen, also habe ich das jetzt falsch hier nachgelesen? Oder also Anpassung könnte man auch sagen, na, aber der bestehenden Systeme in Massad, also ihre Systeme in Masse, die haben ja mit Innenmassage gar nichts zu tun, die hören das ja nur a.
Der ist ja auch ein äh britisches System.
Dann Zerberus, zukunftsfähige Erweiterung bestehender Erfassungstechnologien und
Systeme. Ziel des Vorhabens ist es, neue Fähigkeiten der Satellitenaufklärung zu schaffen,
Fähigkeiten der Satelliten, Kabel und Kurzwellenaufklärung auf den Stand der Technik zu halten und bedarfsgerecht auszubauen, um angesichts des schnellen technologischen Fortschritts auch
künftig in moderne Telekommunikationssysteme eindringen zu können.
Mein Gott, der Fübut dreht sich ja im Grab um.
Ja. Sehr zerborus die alte äh.
Mailboxinfrastruktur. Nein, es war ein ein System, ein ein Netzwerk von Mailboxen, die die Mailbox hieß Bionic.
Stimmt, die ist Bayonic.
Trotzdem war das ja eher zur Freiheits- und so weiter. Warum der Name Zerborus, der Höhlenhund da überhaupt angemessen war, weiß ich nicht. Äh wahrscheinlich wegen seiner dreiköpfigen.
Erscheinungsform dieses normalerweise auch total hipp mit mehr als einem System am Start zu sein.
Und dann haben wir noch das Projekt Vista, die Verbesserung der Informationsverarbeitungs und Selektionsfähigkeit der technischen Aufklärung,
Das Vorhaben hat das Ziel
aus den erfassbaren Kommunikationsverkehren nur die Nachrichtendienstlich relevanten Daten in den Bearbeitungsprozess einzusteuern. Gleichzeitig werden bestehende Fähigkeiten im Bereich des Wissensmanagements ausgebaut. Äh das heißt übersetzt ähm.
Die ganze Scheiße, die wir da sammeln, müssen wir irgendwie auch äh kategorisieren, katalogisieren und durchsuchbar machen. Das ist das. Also das ist,
könnte sagen, das ist äh da wir da wird Ex-Kiescore äh der Name wird da schon so ein bisschen fallen, aber der war eben auch schon vergeben,
Das heißt, ab Sinn Zerverus und Vista äh sind die Antworten des BND. Das Ganze äh mal wieder ein äh League bei Netzpolitik Dot Org aufgearbeitet von,
Andre,
Meister, der da auch sehr viele äh verschiedene Steakholder zur zur Rede äh kommen lässt äh zur Sprache kommen lässt. Ähm die eben Satellitentelefone nutzen, also zum Beispiel auch äh Ruben Neugebauer von Seawatch, ja.
Ähm die auch natürlich auf hoher See äh auf Satellitentelefone angewiesen sind.
Ja, Projekt Vista klingt ja so ein bisschen zu ein guter Plan für den für den Podcast, ne? Verbesserung der Informationsverarbeitung und Selektionsfähigkeit der technischen Aufklärung.
Hat sich die Truppe ja dann gleich zum Ziehen nehmen.
Also.
Jetzt ist die Frage, also in Massad ist halt ein britisches System, diese Satellitensysteme sind ja, das ist eine, also Satellitentelefonie ist ziemlich teuer, funktioniert über Satelliten, hat eingeschränkten Empfang in. Das ist jetzt eher was für im Freien.
Auf dem See, für in der Wüste, für irgendwo.
Da wo du keine, da wo du mit normalen Mobilfunknetzen nicht weit kommst.
Plattformen.
Ah genau, ne, da holst du halt äh Satellitentelefone raus und ähm.
Satellitentelefone haben also,
gab es ja auch schon diese, die wohnen ja auch für Drohnen oder zumindest von den Geheimdiensten zur Lokalisation genutzt, weil die hm in ihrem Signaling-Channel irgendwie äh,
in ihrem Control-Channel quasi auch so Location-Daten quasi durchgegeben haben und so. Also da kannst du über Satellitentelefone, kannst du ganz gut Leute orten,
Und zwar ähm ohne da zu sein, ne? Also äh beim Mobiltelefon musst du äh m.
Irgendwie in der Nähe rumfliegen, ja.
Am Ende dann irgendwo in der Nähe sein für die letzten paar Meter äh und beim Satellitentelefon.
Nur in der Nähe des richtigen Planeten sein.
Muss äh auf auf der richtigen Hälfte des Planetens in der Antenne haben. Ähm.
Na ja, also da äh zur Vertiefung der Artikel von Andre Meister, Geheimes Projekt ab sind der BND arbeitet an einer erheblichen Erweiterung seiner Satellitenüberwachung.
Ja. Kommen wir zu unserem Lieblingsthema. Zu einem der Lieblingsthemen des des Chaos-Computerclubs.
Und zwar Wahlcomputer. Gibt's ja eigentlich nicht mehr,
heißt es, hieß es vor allem auch in äh Holland, die ja schon zweitausendneun im,
als Reaktion auf die Veröffentlichung des Brits. Äh wir vertrauen Wahlcomputer nicht, das ganze auch holländisch Punkt NL
ich kann's nicht richtig aussprechen. Und ähm ja, das war ja ein großer Skandal, woraufhin halt alle Wahlcomputer eingestampft wurden,
sieht aber ganz so aus, als ob noch ein paar übrig geblieben sind.
Denn ähm nun hat sich herausgestellt, dass tatsächlich das ganze Tabulieren dieser ganzen Ergebnisse nach wie vor von einer Software gemacht wird und zwar von einer Software aus Deutschland. Die heißt,
IVU Punkt Elect,
und es von einem deutschen Unternehmenssitz in Berlin IV Traffic Technologies AG, die machen so allerlei, was weiß ich, Flopmanagement,
Pipapo und unter anderem halt auch sowas. Total geile Software, wenn man der Beschreibung auf der Webseite glauben darf äh,
daran zu zweifeln scheint aber ganz angemessen zu sein, weil äh ja nun haben sich mal ein paar Leute etwas näher damit beschäftigt und festgestellt, das Ding ist äh eine ziemliche Katastrophe, aber mal ganz unabhängig davon,
so eine Software äh jetzt besonders gut programmiert ist oder nicht, ist sie natürlich grundsätzlich in dem Wahlprozess ein Problem, wie wir hier schon mehrfach ausgeführt haben,
entziehen sich die Computer einfach der Beobachtbarkeit und das ist nun mal etwas was in einem Wahlprozess,
Unserer Auffassung nach zumindest nichts zu suchen hat.
Nun ist mal ein bisschen panisch geworden in Holland und hat jetzt auch äh für die nächste Wahl äh angekündigt, auch darauf zu verzichten,
um einfach mal ganz sicher zu gehen, dass äh ein ganz gute Maßnahme, denn ähm.
In aller Munde ist die potenzielle Hackbarkeit von Computern und insbesondere auch das große Interesse fremder Staaten
Russland
am Einfluss an der Einflussnahme von solchen Wahlen, das haben wir nun in den USA gesehen, was dort alles passiert ist, also nicht nur Wahlcomputer wurden gehackt, sondern generell elektronische Systeme und ich habe auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass wir jetzt so,
Punkt erreicht haben, in der Weltwahrnehmung. Der ist eigentlich ganz interessant und eigentlich eigentlich auch ganz positiv.
Mittlerweile muss man das irgendwie keinem mehr erklären. Also das war ja noch vor vor kurzer Zeit konntest du den Mundfussel sich reden und sagen,
Ja hier aber seht ihr nicht das potenzielle Bedrohungspotenzial, weil das und das unsicher ist und dann wurde es so zur Kenntnis genommen. Ja, aber,
macht ja keiner. Und dieses,
Die sind diesen letzten Schritt zu denken, dass dass das so Einflussnahme und Global Skale über elektronische Infrastruktur, dass das ein Ding ist.
Die Glocke ist jetzt echt geleuchtet worden. Und das setzt sich gerade so ein bisschen durch, zumindest in den Niederlanden.
Ja äh stellt sich raus, gucke mal da, diese Software ist auch in Deutschland im Einsatz,
teilweise wohl bei Parteien, aber eben auch beim Tabulieren von Wahlergebnissen in Deutschland.
Natürlich erstmal die Frage warum äh und vor allem wenn es denn schon gemacht wird. Stellt es denn ein konkretes Problem dar.
Jetzt ähm hat sich so ein holländischer Hacker das Ding mal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut und ähm wurde äh ja, wurde überhaupt nicht fertig damit
potenzielle Sicherheitslücken aufzudecken und zwar ohne dass er jetzt große akribische äh Sizierung der Software vorgenommen hätte und was weiß ich, den den Source Code sich reasembliert und durchgeschaut hätte
War überhaupt nicht erforderlich. Die ersten zehn zwanzig Sicherheitsbedingten kamen schon äh auf, nachdem man sich nur YouTube-Videos angeschaut haben, die diese Firma selber
oder zumindest oder die Holländer in dem Fall genau die ins Netz gestellt haben, um Leute, die diese Software benutzen, zu instruieren, wie sie den benutzen, ja? Also und und,
ehrlich gesagt, wenn man schon so ein bisschen Erfahrung hat mit Computer und Computersoftwarebedienung, da wird einem schon nur,
Beim Betrachten dieser Videos schon so ein bisschen schlecht, weil die Hilflosigkeit, mit der da überhaupt mit dieser Software operiert wird, die ist schon äh bisschen frappierend, aber dann eben auch die
die die kleinen Gatter und Ringe durch die man da springen muss, um diese Software überhaupt ordentlich zu benutzen und da den Datenfluss sozusagen ähm ja.
Einzuleiten oder am Laufen zu halten es ist wirklich eine Katastrophe. Ich will euch jetzt hier nicht mit tausend Details nerven, aber selbstverständlich,
werden dort natürlich nur unzureichende Sicherheitsvorkehrungen vorgenommen, eine Software, die auf einem Computer läuft äh
hält es für notwendig, um sich benutzen zu lassen, ein Webserver dafür aufzumachen, damit man das über einen Browser benutzen kann. Also das ist noch nicht mal so eine richtige Desktop-Software, sondern es ist einfach nur so ein, so ein Javablock
der da irgendwie auf äh Rickfest äh
reagiert, natürlich alles komplett unverschlüsselt und Pipapo mit tausend äh Anfängerfehlern der Security, mit irgendwie äh Kies in URLs und bliste ich das durch, dass es da der Roll sich einem wirklich die Fußnägel hoch.
Also er hat irgendwie es gibt einen wunderschönen Blogpost, wo dann äh ein der endet mit einem Überblick über die
Risiken, die entdeckt wurden und es sind fünfundzwanzig. Der fünfundzwanzigste ist, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Genau, also irgendwann hört man da auch auf, ja.
Also das ist äh von vorne bis hinten ein einziges Desaster und das ist dieses Software, wenn der Dargener einmal die ganzen Zahlen rein und dann sagt die, was das Ergebnis ist und dann ist gut,
ja? Und ähm,
Da wird halt irgendwie über äh über also da ist einfach einmal alles falsch gemacht. Alles falsch und unsicher, ne?
Ja und nicht nur und nicht nur die Software, also es ist nicht so, dass die Software selber jetzt nur das einzige Problem wäre, sondern schon an diesem Video merkt man.
Der der vollständige Prozess.
Das das Konzept das der Mangel eines Konzeptes für die vollständige Absicherung des Workflows
Der ist so immer nennt, also man man merkt einfach, dass Leute hilflos vor einer Maschine stehen und ihre volle Konzentration darauf konzentriert
überhaupt die Daten an der richtigen Stelle zu haben, da wird dann im Dateisystem rumkopiert, eine Dateien und XML-Dateien hin und her und dann musst du das hier reintun und währenddessen tauchen dann noch irgendwie X Netzwerkchars auf und du merkst schon so, das ist irgendwie alles eine
offene schwere Wunde, wo schon so die Maden herausgekrochen kommt,
Also es ist wirklich also es macht einen fassungslos wie viel Inkompetenz sich breit
machen kann. Also ich meine, dass dass es jetzt solche Systeme gibt. Ja, meinetwegen und wenn dann irgendwie so ein so ein Kegelclub alle neune, äh, damit seine Vorstandswahlen irgendwie äh irgendwohin übertragen will,
meinetwegen selber Schuld, ja, aber das ist äh äh definitiv nichts, was im politischen System was zu suchen hat, schon gar nicht bei äh irgendwelchen Wahlen und natürlich überhaupt
bei äh nationalen Wahlen. Ja, jetzt hat der Club dazu eine.
Erstmal haben wir die Niederhände, also erstmal haben die Niederlande, die Verwendung dieser Software untersagt.
Wird äh also nach diesem Blogpost haben die Niederländer gesagt, der sie hat das zuständigen Ministerium gesagt, dass,
wird nicht mehr benutzt bei uns in der Wahl. Und äh wir haben Angst, äh dass die äh Wahlmodi, dass die das ausländische Mächte unsere Wahl
manipulieren. Zweitausendelf hatte es, wurden auch schon erhebliche Sicherheitsprobleme in der damaligen Version der Software aufgedeckt. Da gab's aber dann keine Reaktion, ne? Also es ist genau das, was du auch gerade.
Wenn man das einfach überhaupt nicht
wenn man, wenn man das Bedrohungsszenario dahinter überhaupt nicht gesehen hat, so. Ja, wieso, das wird doch noch alles nur von unseren kompetenten Mitarbeitern äh benutzt, den läuft auch sonst keiner rum und überhaupt und äh wollen sie mir jetzt erzählen, dass hier die Dämonen äh durch die Wand gekrochen kommen,
Ja genau das. Genau das passiert ja. Da kommt dann der Zerberus äh angeflogen.
Jetzt hat der Club das für eine Pressemitteilung rausgehauen und bittet um äh Spenden, aber ihr könnt die Brieftasche äh gleich stecken lassen. Es geht nicht um Geld
sondern wir brauchen mal wieder Datenspenden
Denn irgendjemand benutzt ja diese Software offensichtlich da draußen und ähm sollte also jemand äh eines entsprechenden Codes da habhaft werden können, würden wir uns über Sicherheitskopien freuen, weil das äh könnte unter Umständen die Debatte um den Einsatz äh dieser Software und ähnlicher Software äh nochmal etwas vertiefen.
Und ich denke mal, das ist natürlich auch vollkommen klar, das hat äh zu fallen und das äh das das kann sich Deutschland überhaupt nicht leisten in diesem Jahr äh auf solche Prozesse zu setzen. Muss auch sagen, ich habe da auch relativ wenig für also ich ich habe Verständnis.
Ich hab Verständnis dafür dass man so 'n komplexen Vorgang wie das Einsammeln von,
Wahlergebnissen, die ja dann sozusagen in einem Wahllokal nach einem definierten Prozess,
ja im Prinzip schon hergestellt werden. Dass das Einsammeln in irgendeiner Form eine Automatisierung erfährt,
Damit das ganze systemisch und und auch korrekt und äh im Idealfall natürlich auch nachvollziehbar erfahren kann,
Was aber nicht passieren darf ist dass.
Dass das so passiert.
Das ist super Signal, vor allem zählt ja erstmal, dass das dann quasi die ultimative Aussage ist. Also äh diese Informationen müssen in dem Moment, wo sie festgestellt werden und damit meine ich,
Die Auszählung der Papierscheinchen in den Wahllokalen. Da gibt es ja einen Moment,
Muss ich dann alle über den Zettel rüberbeugen, alles ist zusammengezählt. Das ist dann das Wahlergebnis. Und so wie das jetzt hier mit dieser Software läuft,
man irgendwie diese Information auf irgendwelche USB-Sticks äh gepackt, die mit dem Booten irgendwohin gefahren, eingesammelt in diese Software reingetan, teilweise wurden dann auch äh diese diese XML Dateien, die dabei rauskamen
mit per E-Mail weitergeschickt, also man man fragt sich wirklich, was Sache ist und die einzige Integritätssicherung war, dass man da so einen Hashkey erzeugt, ja? Also so eine.
Genau, also.
Eins neben dir das.
Genau, also der der also erstmal ein ein vollkommen Outdate äh Algorithmus ist, den man einfach nicht mehr benutzen sollte für solche Sachen, aber selbst wenn man ihn äh nutzt, dann macht man das halt nicht so, dass man mit der Datei auch noch gleich den Key mit dazu gibt, ja? Das so. Ja, nee, ist äh kein Problem, ist alles verschlüsselt
ist alles kryptographisch abgesichert, das Passwort steht auch gleich daneben, ja? Das ist so, als ob du ein Schlüssel neben deinem Tresor hängst. Wieso ist er abgeschlossen.
Das ist eher da, also das ist da ist einfach alles falsch so. Alles. So, da ist hat auch nie irgendeiner drüber nachgedacht.
Ja, schlimm. Ja, ich wollte mal kurz darauf hinaus. Also.
Man kann natürlich Software benutzen, um das alles zu butabulieren und et cetera, aber man muss natürlich aufpassen, dass das nicht der definierende äh Workflow ist, der sagt, was die Wahrheit dieser Wahl ist
Ja, man kann natürlich äh diese sich andere Methoden äh ausdenken, wie die Wahllokale, ihre Informationen öffentlich machen und das sollten sie vielleicht auch,
genau so tun, näm.
Wer das, wer das designt hat, ne? Er hat da das wurde nicht designed, würde ich fast sagen. Also da hat niemand,
auch überhaupt nur eine äh das gibt ja auch den Workflow einfach gar nicht wieder, ne? Was du eigentlich haben wollen würdest, wäre ähm.
Ach komm. Du, also du könntest zum Beispiel sowas machen mit ähm äh Signaturkarten,
Jeder Wahlleiter oder was hat eine Signaturkarte, mit der er
eine Signatur anbringen kann und nachher prüfst du, ob das, was dir da eingereicht wurde äh von dieser Signaturkarte signiert wurde, dann weißt du, das hast du von diesem Wahlleiter bekommen
Das Ding per E-Mail zu zu transportieren. Schick mal per E-Mail die Wahlergebnisse rüber.
Also und äh es gibt danach auch keine weiteren ähm.
Äh keine weiteren äh Nachkontrollen oder so, ne? Das ist äh wird dann einmal alles in diesen großen Beinaryblock geworfen und dann sagt der, äh hier, der hat gewonnen. Es ist eine.
Ja und vor allem wenn man sich dieses Video anschaut, da ist ja auch schon relativ wahrscheinlich, dass da einfach mal zwanzig Wahlkreise äh schon auf Datei, Kopierebene miteinander verwechselt werden, ein Drama.
Und du hast und du hast vor allem sehr schön ähm.
Also was du hier hast, ist alles eigentlich noch schlimmer als Wahlcomputer, denn so wenn ihr jetzt das Wahlcomputer, dann musst du ja immerhin noch diese ganzen inhardware dort stehenden Wahlcomputer irgendwie infizieren, ne.
Wenn du so eine Software da hast, dann kannst du auf einer ganz anderen Ebene,
Nachdem die Leute sich mit der von uns immer hochgelobten Papier und Bleistiftwahl auseinandergesetzt haben und das gute Gefühl gewählt zu haben
erlebt haben, kannst du immer noch hingehen und sagen, woah, hier plus eins oder minus zehn, ne? Also das ist ähm
haarsträubend und das.
Ja, ich meine, das wird jetzt wird natürlich in den Kommentaren der berechtigte Einwand kommen. Na ja, aber die Wahl lokal E
sind ja sozusagen auch öffentlich und die hätten ja da auch vor Ort überprüft werden können und wer dann dabei ist, kann sich die ja auch aufschreiben et cetera
Frage ist nur, wem wird halt am Ende dann äh geglaubt, ja, wenn wenn die ganzen Originalzettel nicht mehr da sind
Und von daher müsste man sich eben eh überlegen, ob nicht diese Information in dem Moment, wo Wahllokale sie feststellen, in dem Moment auch gleich öffentlich gemacht werden müssen.
Du hast vor allem also da müsste es, die werden ja dann,
in anderen komischen Formaten irgendwo in irgendeiner Wahl ergeben. Also das geht so nicht, so geht das nicht. Und äh man kann da äh man kann da halt vernünftige Systeme machen,
wo man zumindest einfach einmal sicherstellt, dass also alles was du brauchst ist, du brauchst ja im Prinzip nur zwei Dinge, drei. Du brauchst ein standardisiertes Format wie ein Wahlkreis seine Ergebnisse dort abliefert,
Er musste irgendwie von der Eingabemaske her sicherstellen, dass er die dreimal kontrolliert und alles einzelne bestätigt und sagt, ja, so und so viele hundert Stimmen für äh die und hier die Wiese und jene Partei.
Dann willst du eine verschlüsselte Übertragung haben. Einfach damit, also damit es verschlüsselt ist. Warum solltest du es nicht machen,
Wichtiger ist aber die äh signierte Übertragung, ne? Also eigentlich am Ende soll's eh öffentlich sein, die auf die Verschlüsselung könntest du also unter Umständen sogar verzichten. Aber du willst eine Signatur haben
Äh der ist also
Dieses Ergebnis und kein anderes und auch nur einmal ein Ergebnis von einem Wahlleiter eingereicht wird. Und dann kannst du nämlich anhand der Signatur
erstens sehen, das ist nicht verändert worden, sondern das ist das, was der Wahlleiter uns übermitteln wollte,
Zweitens kannst du auch automatisch dann sehen, dass es signiert mit dem Kie von dem Wahlleiter. Also ist das von diesem einen Wahlbüro und wird entsprechend in unserer Software ähm ähm,
auch interpretiert und und ausgewiesen. Dann kannst du, dann hast du noch eine, dann macht die Software ihre Magie,
Das müsstest du, das muss dann natürlich auch nochmal irgendwie einen vernünftigen Code Review unterzogen werden, aber das sind quasi die die Grundgedanken,
Wenn du dir darüber Gelegen Gedanken machst, dass du irgendwie diese weiß nicht wie viel hundert oder tausend Wahlkreise in Deutschland hast oder Wahllokale in Deutschland hast und diesen ganzen Mist irgendwie innerhalb kürzester Zeit,
äh in in so eine Software gießen möchtest, ne? Und dann kannst du natürlich äh dann kannst du dir.
Also das ist jetzt keine unlösbare Aufgabe, sowas zu machen. Am Ende macht das Ding ein paar Berechnungen und dann ist gut. Du musst nur natürlich irgendwie diesen Trail nachvollziehen können. Und
genau der Wahlleiter, der ihn wieder hinschickt oder der Wahlbeaufsichtiger, wer auch immer das dann ist, der dann dahin schickt und sagt, hier fünf Mann für für die Partei zehn für die. Der kann ja genau am Ende nicht nacherkennen, ob sein Ergebnis da wirklich drin ist.
Ja und ich meine es sind auch äh generell die Frage, inwiefern man da eben äh auch hier wieder,
digitale gelten lässt, ne? Also am Ende finde ich, müssen da schon von Zeugen unterschriebene Zettel äh müssen da einfach äh versiegelt äh auch einfach nochmal ganz physisch irgendwo zusammengetragen werden und das
darf dann auch gerne die offizielle Quelle sein.
Es ist auch ich sehe äh.
Also aus beruflicher Perspektive sehe ich auch. Also sowas ist auch einfach eine Hygienefrage.
Kannst du auch, du kannst auch hundert Mal irgendwie äh dir vorm Spülen in der Küche nicht die Hände waschen äh und sagen ähm.
Wird schon nichts passieren, ne? Ist trotzdem Scheiße. So so macht man das nicht. Da hat man doch auch ein bisschen Anspruch an seine Zunft, dass man nicht so eine beschissene Software überhaupt auf die Idee kommt, die irgendjemanden anzudrehen,
Ne, das finde ich, also das finde ich das ist eine Schande für alle Programmierer.
Genau, also wir lehnen das aus hygienischen.
Wir lehnen das aus hygienischen Gründen ab und ähm und der CCC ähm hätte gerne eine Datenspende da kommen in Frage ähm insbesondere äh im im Land Brandenburg wurde äh das schon mal äh benutzt
die Software IVU Punkt Elect und verschiedene Landesämter für Statistik arbeiten. Auch mit IVU zusammen. Ähm wenn ihr als Programmierer bei IVU arbeitet, habt ihr jetzt die Möglichkeit, eure Ehre
wieder herzustellen.
Und äh natürlich hat der äh CCC auch die äh diese Pressemitteilung ähm auf Russisch nochmal äh veröffentlicht, um auch wirklich alle äh Interessierten ähm.
Reise zu erreichen. Gut, genug dazu. Gehen wir nach Italien.
Ja, das ist etwas, also das.
Seit zwei Jahren weiß ich, dass sie das vorhaben und ich habe da auch selber ich habe da gemischte Gefühle. Ähm.
Was haben die denn vor?
Ja
Also ähm ein bekannter von mir äh steckt da auch mit drin. Mit dem habe ich da auch vor zwei Jahren oder so zum ersten Mal drüber gesprochen. Ähm in Italien gibt es jetzt einen Vorschlag,
für die Regulation von Staatstrojanern. Die also sagen, pass mal auf, wir haben hier einen Gesetzesvorschlag, so reguliert ihr,
Den Einsatz von Trojanern, weil und das ist natürlich der der Punkt, warum das in der Szene äh kontrovers diskutiert wird. Ähm.
Weil wir ja eigentlich gegen Schlaftrianer sind. Ne? Und jetzt hast du aber natürlich die Situation, dass die zum Einsatz kommen.
So oder.
Und genau das ist das Argument oder die die Rationale dieses Vorstoßes, dass man sagt, das wird so oder so kommen. Der Kampf gegen Staatstrojaner ist wenn nicht jetzt schon verloren, dann zumindest aussichtslos.
Und ähm entsprechend müssen wir uns jetzt auf wenigstens äh darauf an den Punkt bringen, einen,
vernünftigen juristischen Rahmen dafür zu definieren, damit wir dieses Unheil wenigstens in halbwegs sinnvolle Bahnen lenk.
Das ist also die die Gedanke hier. Ich bin da.
Persönlich sehr gespalten zu. Ähm ich glaube aber das Argument ist natürlich erstmal so,
nachvollziehbar und vertretbar und wir schauen uns mal ein bisschen jetzt hier an, was denn da so bei rausgekommen ist. Sie sagen also, okay, wir wir haben erstmal Anforderungen an den juristischen,
Rahmen sagen, da gehen wir einfach in die in die Analogwelt ähm Analogien und sagen.
Telefon, ein Telefon, Abhör Warent, also ein Gerichtsbeschluss zum Anordnung, zum Telefonabhören ist notwendig, um äh WhatsApp Anrufe abzuhören. Eine ähm,
quasi dass der du brauchst eine spezielle Anordnung zur Online-Durchsuchung äh wenn du Dateien von einem befallenen Gerät holen möchtest, ne? Also baust du ein,
Surch in Seasure Warrent, also die online.
Und Feststellung der Daten.
Eine äh die auch in Deutschland sehr viel mit sehr viel höherem Rahmen versehen hat.
Wenn du ähm Webbrowser Sessions,
mitsniffen möchtest, dann brauchst du ein Internet Wire-Taping Warrend und den,
du bräuchtest, wenn du jetzt mit deinem Trojaner äh das Mikrofon anmachen möchtest, den gleichen Warent oder den gleichen Gerichtsbeschluss, mit den gleichen Auflagen, den du bräuchtest, um in die Wohnung einzubrechen und und Mikrofone zu verstecken.
Das schon mal ähm klingt jetzt äh erstmal,
naheliegend und nicht besonders radikal, aber ist natürlich ein Punkt. Das muss ja erstmal definieren, weil wie wir ja wissen, wurde ja in der Vergangenheit
öfter bei Staatstrojanern äh bedauerliche Fehler gemacht äh und äh diese dann in einem Unfu,
In einem Funktionsumfang ausgeliefert, der äh jenseits von Gut und Böse war. Und dann sagen sie, naja und für die Technik haben wir,
auch noch äh einige Anforderungen, ich glaube nicht, dass ich die jetzt vollständig aufzähle. Ähm wir wollen.
Dass der Source Code bei irgendeiner vertrauenswürdigen Institution hinterlegt ist und mit einem Repreducible Bild verifizierbar ist. Ähm Repreducible Bild äh klingt schwierig, vor allem wenn ich das ausspreche.
Einfach reproduzierbare Herstellung der tatsächlichen ausführbaren Datei, al,
dass das, was dann letzten Endes läuft, klar ist, wie man das äh herstellt, woraus das hergestellt wird und wie man feststellen kann, im Idealfall, was dann am Ende auch tatsächlich zum Einsatz kam.
Ja und das ist also der der Teufel im steckt hier im Detail. Es ist nämlich so, wenn du auf deinem Computer ein eine Software von gegebener Komplexität,
kompelierst und dann eine Prüfsumme darüber machst über das Ergebnis und das dann nochmal machst, ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass das Ergebnis unterschiedlich ist.
Denn der Bildprozess ist nicht vollständig deterministisch, da kommen verschiedene
abhängige äh Einflüsse mit rein, die winzige Bits in der Datei, kleine Teile der Datei, immer wieder ein bisschen variieren lassen.
Weil da zum Beispiel irgendwo das Datum, an dem das gemacht wird, reingeschrieben wird und schon ändern sich die Bits.
Ja, da gehört ne, also eine Sekunde später kommt halt äh und äh dann wird das irgendwie äh kommt halt ein, ein äh anderes äh Ergebnis bei raus. Minimal, aber für eine Prüfsumme reicht's ja. Deswegen haben wir beim,
einunddreißig C drei glaube ich, auch auf meiner Einladung hin einen schönen Talk zu gehabt von äh Mike Parry und anderen. Ähm,
Bilds. Ähm die haben das nämlich mit dem äh Torbrowser gemacht und mit anderen,
mit anderer Software und haben damit genau hier der schön war dabei und Hans Steiner war nicht dabei, steht aber noch hier bei Media CCC. Ähm,
Das ist ganz interessant, weil du willst also,
identische Binaries am Ende haben. Und das ist äh relativ äh da musst du deinen Bildprozess sehr, sehr genau dokumentieren und äh schaffen, dass das ähm,
dass das passieren kann. Aber dass das wirklich möglich ist, dann hast du aber eben auch was, dass Leute
selber bauen, können den Source Code und auch bei einem anderen Bein nur sagen können, ja, das ist dieser Source Code, ja? Das ist normaler, also ist normale Umstände unter normalen Umständen oft nicht der Fall.
Ähm und sagen sie, das muss also da sein, damit
wirklich eine Beweiskette von vorne bis hinten da ist, dass dieses Bino diesen ähm diesem Source Code entspricht. Dann jede Handlung
die dieser Trojaner ausführt, muss äh dokumentiert und gelockt werden in einer äh Manipulationssicheren
verifizierbaren Weise, ja? Das heißt, du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie
was irgendwelchen Mist machen und das dann nachher wieder die Zeile aus dem Lok löschen, sondern der muss im Prinzip so eine Art Hashtag oder sowas machen, wo er sagt, jedes, bei jedem neuen Schritt quasi alle davor gegangenen mit in die Prüfsumme aufnimmt und dann hast du eine Kette
wo du weißt, okay, hier hat jetzt nicht einer etwas zwischendurch rausgenommen, weil dann würde diese äh Prüfsummenkette nicht mehr
validieren. Wäre einem eine mögliche Implementation davon.
Ähm sie sagen also kryptografisches Times Tamping und digitales Signieren, äh sodass du eine, dass der äh.
Der Angeklagte, die Ergebnisse fair anfechten kann, ne.
Und eben auch vollständig da hat und man alles sieht, was dieser Trojaner getan hat.
Ähm er darf nicht äh das Sicherheitslevel, der Devices, auf den er aktiviert wurde, herabsetzen. Ähm das ist ein.
Klingt auch wieder erstmal relativ einfach, aber da da wittere ich natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Falle, weil ähm für,
so was wie ein iPhone, was meine steile These im Moment der sicherste Computer ist, der im Con Supermarkt erhältlich ist. Ähm.
Steile These. Ähm aber ich habe weiß halt ungefähr, wie schwierig das ist, aber da musst du.
Es soll nicht der einzige, der sich Jesus vertritt.
Brauchst du einen, brauchst du halt einen Dellbreak um um diesen Trojaner anzubringen. Und wenn's keinen Jaybreak gibt, dann kriegst du den Trojaner auch nicht da drauf,
das wäre hier dieser dieser Fall wäre würde im Prinzip sagen,
Dann seh mal zu, wie du ein äh äh wie du dein, wie du den danach wieder anbaust, äh wie du den äh wie du den Jabrik danach wieder loswirst äh ohne eben die Gesamtsicherheit des Systemes äh zu beeinträchtigen.
Dass es halt in seltensten Fällen der Fall, weil.
Würden die am Ende umgehen, indem sie den Trojaner von Apple signieren lassen, ne? Also das.
Ja gut klar in in dem Moment wo der Hersteller da mitspielt ja hast du ja quasi so einen Trojaner AP. Dann äh ist das vielleicht alles zu erfüllen, aber dann musst du halt fragen, wie du nach deinem Hersteller vertrauen solltest.
Ones, die Investigation Hass Finish the Trouge in Must bean Instalt, orderweise Deteld instructions on how to self Removed
Muskelprovided. Also wenn vorbei ist, die Untersuchung vorbei ist, dann muss der auch wieder deinstalliert werden, kann's nicht einfach drauf lassen und sagen, wir greifen nicht mehr drauf zu. Ähm dann sagen sie.
Das könnte Ikea auch mal einführen, ne, wie man die Dinger zusammenbaut, das das kriegen sie mal ganz gut hin, aber wenn wir die mal auseinanderbauen soll, soweier.
Dann die Produktion des Trojaners muss nachvollziehbar sein bei einer etablierten, nationalen Trojaner Registry, äh wo du den Fingerprint jeder einzelnen Version der Software äh,
die eingesetzt wurde, einmal abgibst und sagst, es wurde verwendet, Trojaner mit der Prüfsumme so und so,
Und hier ist er jetzt registriert. Ähm,
Die Trojaner müssen zertifiziert werden. Äh jährlich äh muss diese Zertifizierung erneut erneuert werden, äh damit und mit dieser Zertifizierung muss sichergestellt werden, dass sie ähm Gesetzes,
treu.
Und der technischen Regulierung entsprechend sind, ne? Also muss einfach neu nur jedes Jahr einmal zum TÜV, muss alles andere auch äh oder alle, ne.
Äh
Dann sagen sie, das ist auch nochmal ein wichtiger Punkt. Äh die extrahierten Daten müssen bei dem äh Pro-Secuter gespeichert werden und müssen vor dem Zugriff dritter.
Durch Verschlüsselung geschützt werden,
Und ähm das macht vor allem Sinn im Blick auf den Teil H. Trojaner müssen direkt von der Polizei operiert werden und dürfen nicht von und nicht von privaten Dienstleistern.
Äh das ist äh das wird äh da werden jetzt aber in Italien äh die guten Leute von Hacking Team.
Mal ihre äh Lobbyisten äh in die Runde schicken. Äh da ist aber äh Mailand in Not, wenn äh wenn äh wenn wenn das durchkommt.
So ja das macht,
das sind schon relativ sinnvolle Überlegungen die angestellt werden und ich weiß dass,
die auch äh schon lange Zeit äh also die haben wie gesagt zwei Jahre daran äh gearbeitet mit allen möglichen Leuten geredet. Ähm.
Es ist ein heißes Eisen, weil das eben heißt so, du hast jetzt im Prinzip, damit gehst du einmal voran.
Und saß Trojaner äh.
Unsastrojaner. So könnte er das machen. Und ähm das ist der Grund, warum mir das natürlich irgendwie,
auch weh tut, aber,
Alles in allem sind diese Bedingungen, kann man eigentlich sagen, dass du kein, also dass es unter Verletzung dieser Bedingungen? Willst du auf jeden Fall keine Staatstrüne haben, egal welche dieser Bedingungen.
Im Prinzip auch die genau die Kernkritikpunkte sind, die in den ganzen Trojaner Diskussionen immer wieder aufgebracht worden sind, ne? Was was macht das Ding? Kann das überhaupt bewiesen werden, kann bewiesen werden, dass genau das lief
was bleibt auf dem Rechner zurück? Ist dadurch sozusagen weitere Sicherheitseinschränkungen verbunden et cetera. Da sind ja alle im Prinzip genau die Antworten auf diese Fragen und man dreht es eigentlich nur um und sagt
Wenn ihr das alles sicherstellen könnt, ja dann äh meinetwegen, weil dann ist
auch der das Ausmaß äh einer einer einer derkollateralschäden zumindest kalkulierbar,
Oder zumindest in einem gewissen Maße äh abfederbar, ja? Also es ist sozusagen
bewegt sich in einem Rahmen und vor allem hat es ja auch automatisch eine Auswirkung auf den Prozess, mit dem das Ganze stattfindet. Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine Regelung, die verhindert, dass da jetzt einfach so ein Rog-One äh Team einfach mal äh digital auf alles draufhaut, was äh bei drei auf den Bäumen ist.
Wie das ja heutzutage eigentlich die Regel ist und äh
ist in dem Sinne auch ein Angebot an eine politische Debatte, die einfach Kompromiss getrieben ist, die,
Nun mal die einzige ist, die letzten Endes auch erfolgreich, weil mit permanent, mit, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, äh das ist alles scheiße und nichts darf äh äh jemals passieren
das führt nun ja auch oft dazu, dass in solchen Debatten man dann eben auch einfach schlicht ignoriert wird.
Einem also ich kann würde ja sagen, also diese die machen,
Die sind sinnvoll diese Dinger. Ähm ignorieren aber natürlich trotzdem den Fakt, dass du immer irgendeine Schwachstelle brauchst, um den Trojaner anzubringen und dass es immer besser ist, die zu fixen als ähm,
Als weiter, als, als den Rest der Bevölkerung weiterhin dieser Schwachstelle auszusetzen,
Also das ist jetzt nicht die die Weisheit letzter Schluss aber für das Binery, das sich Trojaner nennt, selber sind das erstmal sinnvolle,
Anwendung wir sinnvolle Verpflichtung unter den ich keinen Frieden geben würde. Ja? Gleichzeitig.
Würdest du dich garantieren, dass du dann nachs Maul hältst, aber.
Ähm vielleicht fände ich's, wäre es auch für für den.
Normal mit dir unterhalten.
Vielleicht wäre es auch für die für äh die weiteren Aktivitäten des Chaos-Computerclubs gar nicht so schlecht. Wenn ein, zwei von den Sachen nicht eingehalten werden, damit wir auch die nächsten Staatstrojaner noch schön in unsere Finger
bekommen und liegen können. Die übrigens auch an das gleiche Postfach, was schon zum.
Ähm zum äh zur Wahlsoftware steht.
Passt viel rein.
Da ist Platz.
Ja
Jetzt hast du gesagt, Vorschlag, kannst du mir nochmal genau sagen, von wem genau das kommt, also äh kommt aus Italien, ist jetzt ein bisschen,
breit. Also es ist jetzt wirklich etwas, was in einem höheren, politischen.
Ebene schon diskutiert wird oder ist das jetzt nur mit einem Vorschlag von irgendjemand aus Italien.
Ähm,
Also eine sind Parlamentarier, Andrea Mazioti, der irgendwie das Constitutional FL, das das Komitee für Verfassungsfragen
äh leitet ähm Stefano, Dambruzo
der ein bekannter Antiterror Strafverfolger ist
Stefano Quintarelli, äh der ein Internetpionier und ähm und äh Unternehmer ist,
ja? Ähm also ist ein ein Schulterschluss von von Zivilgesellschaft und,
einer Gruppe Parlamentarier und ähm noch ein paar anderer Italiener, die ich kenne, die da äh unten dran so gearbeitet haben,
Wichtig ist sowas natürlich in den ähm in den äh also in den ähm.
In den regulären Prozess da irgendwie einzubringen, ne? Also die haben sich offenbar darum bemüht, eben auch Parlamentarier dabei zu haben, damit das Ding nicht einfach irgendwo hingelegt wird und äh dann äh zur Kenntnis genommen wird, sondern jetzt,
Wahrscheinlich auch dem Verwertungsprozess des Parlamentes zugeführt wird.
Gut. Haben jetzt aber noch ein paar kleinere Sachen nehme ich an, ne? Ja.
Kurz Kurzmeldungen,
zwei Jahre lang haben wir da ist nichts mehr passiert, der Bundesgerichtshof hat sich aber jetzt am Dienstag gerade mal wieder äh mit dem Fall beschäftigt.
Ob denn die Einrichtung des Bundes IP-Adressen der Nutzer ihrer Webseite äh speichern dürfen, äh der Rechtsstreit geht jetzt in sein zehntes Jahr äh und ist die Klage des äh Schleswig-Holsteinischen ähm,
Piraten und Ackervorrataktivisten Patrick,
Breyer gegen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Ähm, der möchte ähm äh erreichen, dass sämtlichen Websites des Bundes untersagt wird, IP-Adressen von Website-Besuchern ohne Einwilligung
Monate lang zu speichern und dann natürlich als äh als zweiten Schritt äh dass ähm,
wahrscheinlich auch dann ausweiten, dass eben die IP-Adressen als äh Personen äh zugedachte Daten hier nicht mehr einfach ohne Einstimmung.
Ähm gespeichert werden sollen. Das könnte nochmal interessant werden,
Denn argumentiert wird hier hauptsächlich, dass man diese IP-Adressen aus äh Gründen der Sicherheit zeitlich begrenzt speichern würde. Und ich glaube, das ist ein äh sehr wackeliges Argument, denn deine Speicherung wird nicht wirklich,
sicherer dadurch, dass du dann oder dein dein dein Server wird nicht
wirklich dadurch sicherer, dass du äh die IP-Adressen speicherst, ne? Ähm die können dir aber natürlich bei einer Forensik helfen, bei einer äh
oder bei einer bei besseren Filtern von Angriffen können sie können sie hilfreich sein, aber drei Monate lang äh ist sicherlich nicht notwendig. Äh zum die Sicherheit deiner Informationsverarbeitenden Systeme zu zu sicherzustellen,
Das haben wir also am BGH, sind wir mal gespannt, wie da geurteilt wird.
Dann ähm Kurzmeldung, weil müssen wir uns mal jemanden holen, der sich damit auskennt, dass Freihandelsabkommen CETAN äh wurde äh beschlossen. Das ist also das,
Freiheitsabfreiheitsfreihandelsabkommen zwischen äh EU und Kanada.
Das äh wurde also jetzt vom EU-Parlament mit vierhundertacht äh vier und zweihundertvierundfünfzig Gegenstimmen ähm verabschiedet.
Und kann damit voraussichtlich schon,
in Kraft treten. Ähm aber dann muss es noch ratifiziert werden, das wird aber dann wiederum noch Jahre dauern. Insofern haben wir äh in diesen Jahren dann noch Zeit, uns nochmal mit einem Sondergast äh spezifisch mit CETA außereinander zu setz.
Ja und dann noch ganz kurz in halbwegs eigener Sache, aber weil es für viele unserer Hörer äh sicherlich äh interessant ist, der Prototype Fund geht in die nächste Runde. Prototype Fund ist dieses äh Projekt von.
Und dem, welches Ministerium ist das denn dann nochmal? BMW oder sowas,
irgend so ein Ministerium,
Das äh hier ja relativ viel Geld äh für Open Source Projekte äh ausschütten möchte, die der Zivilgesellschaft ähm,
zum zugutekommen. Das Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung.
Ähm gibt hier äh Geld aus und man kann sich mit seinem Open Source Projekt hier äh bewerben, um daran teilzunehmen. Es gibt noch, ich glaube, so ungefähr einen Monat lang, am einunddreißigsten,
dritten oder so ist die Deadline, genau, also ihr habt noch dreiundvierzig Tage, nehmt euch da ein bisschen Zeit für, muss man natürlich ein sinnvolles Proposal schreiben, aber ähm da ähm
Glaube ich, kann man vielleicht das ein oder andere Projekt in verschiedenen Kategorien, die hier Förderungs äh.
Förderungsträchtig sind oder Förderungslegitimiert sind ähm vielleicht ähm.
Ein Teil dieser eins Komma zwei Millionen Euro für sich beanspruchen und was voranbringen.
Inwiefern ist das jetzt eine Meldung in eigener Sache.
Weil ich da zumindest in der ersten Auswahl in der Pre-Jury war und das haben wir auch klar glaube ich damals gesagt dass wir in der Open-Nolle Foundation viele Freunde haben.
Wegen müssen wir hier unsere Unabhängigkeit äh bei dieser Ankündigung durchaus in Frage stellen, wie zum Beispiel auch viele wissen, dass Maria Reimer ja sogar äh bei uns in der zweihundertsten Sendung zu Gast war, die auch bei der Open Nollage Foundation arbeitet.
Wir stecken alle unter einer Decke.
Wir stecken alle unter einer Decke in Berlin. Da könnte er aber von ausgehen.
Sitzen auch alle im selben Boot. Schön. Damit nähern wir uns mit dem Ende, zumindest dieser Sendung. Ähm.
Ich habe noch irgendwie muss nochmal über Facebook reden. Ich habe äh,
Bindebörsenartikel gestolpert, der mich darauf hingewiesen hat, dass es ja jetzt,
Ich bin mir nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, ob das jetzt ein unmittelbares Ergebnis davon war, aber im Prinzip wurde es so darauf zurückgeführt, dass diese ganze Klagerei gegen Facebook,
von Herrn Schrims,
Und die Maximal auch hier äh hatten dann ja auch zur Folge hatte, dass Facebook das ein oder andere Tool äh eingebaut hat und was mir nicht so ganz klar war, dass man wirklich so mit zwei, drei Klicks sich mal so ein Datenexport jetzt mittlerweile generieren kann.
Das fand ich insbesondere deshalb so interessant, nicht nicht, dass da irgendwelche Daten, also also man kann alles exportieren, man kann seine ganzen Postings, Kommentare, Bilder, alles, was man sozusagen hat, kann man exportieren.
Nehme ich an, so sieht es aus, ich habe ja da fast nix liegen, deswegen kann ich das jetzt auch nicht so umfangreich überprüfen, ob damit wirklich alles abgedeckt ist, macht aber so ein bisschen den Eindruck. Und unter anderem kriegt man dann auch äh äh noch ein Export.
Über werbetreibende mit deinen Kontaktinfos.
Wo dann mal sozusagen alle Werbetreibenden aufgeführt sind, ja, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer meine Kontaktinformationen haben. Und ganz ehrlich, ich mache.
Wenig bis gar nichts mit Facebook. Ich habe diesen Account, ich squatte den eigentlich so im Wesentlichen und es ist so so ein bisschen so mein mein Balkon, wo ich da so sitze und mir das Treiben so aus einer größeren Entfernung anschaue, aber ab und zu muss man ja mal was,
Gucken.
So ne.
Muss man nicht hin.
Ist schon ich muss das, weil ich.
Ab und zu muss der Podcast Papst mal ausm.
Ne, ich habe eigentlich in fast jedem Netzwerk einen Account so und je nachdem wie sehr mich das äh
reißt oder so, mache ich da halt mehr oder weniger, aber anschauen tue ich mir eigentlich alles. Also ich will jetzt auch nicht immer so dieser Kritiker aus der Ferne sein, der äh sich eigentlich nichts anguckt und dann zu keinem irgendwie eine zunächst eine Aussage machen kann. Manche Dinge.
Rufen mich so wenig, dass ich mich eben auch kaum damit beschäftige, aber ich beschäftige mich zumindest immer ein bisschen damit. Na ja, auf jeden Fall.
Die Liste der Werbetreibenden, meinen Kontaktinfos, ja ist einhundertdreiundvierzig Unternehmen lang.
Und die haben welche da, welche Kontaktinfo.
Das weiß ich nicht. Hier steht nur Werbetreibende mit deinen Kontaktinfos, das steht nicht. Wer das ist. Welche Kontaktinfos sie haben? Welche Werbung? Ja, das steht hier.
Aber welche Werbetreibenden? Sollen wir mal, sollen wir dem mal ein paar Spam E-Mail schicken?
Na gut, das sind jetzt einfach.
Hören sie, Lockbruch, Netzpolitik, diese Woche fünf Euro billiger, Penisverlängerung durch Netzpolitik.
Ja, also bei einigen habe ich das Gefühl, die hören das schon, bei anderen,
habe ich noch nicht mal eine Ahnung, was das irgendwie sein sollte. Ja, aber ist schon interessant mit was man hier alles äh in Kontakt äh tritt offenbar,
ohne jemals mit denen in Kontakt, also sind Unternehmen, die ich gar nicht kenne, wo ich mich wirklich frage, woher,
Also warum? Also auf welcher Basis äh wer werde ich denn da jetzt ans Messer geliefert oder zumindest äh datenmäßig.
Auf Basis von die Zahlen.
Also Airbnb selber ist in dieser Liste, glaube ich, irgendwie drei oder vier, fünf Mal drin. Das ist auch schon mal sehr interessant. Also die scheinen auch mehrere Instanzen von sich zu haben
Kann ich auf jeden Fall jedem nur äh empfehlen. Ich werde mal diesen,
Artikel noch mit in die Shownotes mit aufnehmen, da könnt ihr dann auch mal alle schön exportieren, vielleicht habt ihr da auch Interesse, weil ich glaube, das Feature hat nicht jeder unbedingt entdeckt.
Wo ist das, Fita? Wo da, also Facebook ist ein Dschungel. Ich bin ja hauptsächlich deshalb nicht auf Facebook, weil sich mir dieses User-Intervalls nicht erschlie.
Der ja das ähm,
ist auch so, äh ist es eigentlich ganz einfach, man muss so wie den Settings das richtige Menü finden und dann kann man da ein ein Download Your Information
anklicken und dann klickt man den an und dann läuft das so Asynchron und dann kriegt man irgendwann nochmal eine Mail, wenn's fertig ist, das ging bei mir relativ schnell, das mag bei anderen Leuten länger dauern und dann geht man da nochmal auf die Seite und dann kriegt man da so einen Sipp runtergeladen und da ist dann irgendwie im Idealfall ist drin.
Mhm. Das ist dann jetzt das, was dann demnächst irgendwie Boarder äh Leute haben wollen, ne.
Genau, laden laden sie doch mal für uns mal alles runter, dass wir das dann mal äh haben. Na ja.
Alles in alles in der Debatte, ne? Also,
Identifikation von also Kontrolle von Personen an der Grenze, Identifikation von Asylsuchenden. Alles alles schon in der Mache Tim. Kannst du dann schon mal, wenn du jetzt hier, ist eigentlich mit, hast du bisher keine Witze mehr bei der Staatsbürgerschaft machen,
Na gut, dann sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Oder? Dann danken wir, äh danke ich noch Jan und Markus.
Ja und ich danke allen anderen und äh wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder.
Wie viel MB hast du eigentlich bei Facebook? MB was. MB.
MB was. Datenexport. Ähm nicht eins.
Neunhundertsiebenundneunzig Kilo bald und davon ist das allermeiste meine Profilfotos, die ich sowieso überall im Netz habe. Also ich habe kein einziges Foto, was nicht von mir ist.
Also ich bin da sehr datensparsam, das kann ich dir sagen.
Wer bietet weniger an.
Wer bietet weniger?
So, damit zurück.
Die Welt. Macht's gut. Ciao, ciao.
Ciao, ciao.